netley Crunch at one point was a Crispy
Crunchy kind of poppy experience and it
fell off it's just chewy it's like St
the stere the cereal in it now feels
almost stale to me like it's like the
crunch part is gone if I didn't have
nougat for the rest of my life I
wouldn't care I could sacrifice nougat
in my life I would take Milky Way over
the Nestle Crunch any day of the week
well I I still would take Nestle and not
of course yeah can I say Butterfinger is
probably the only candy that while
eating it I'm like I'm so sick of this
goddamn candy oh that's a really good
point I literally I'll eat rollos it's a
decent sized bar they are big bars and
by the time you're about halfway through
you're like I've had enough of whatever
this is what is this glue stick I'm
eating I don't like it